I then reject nation I'm Greg Alva and
I'm John Humphrey AVENGERS endgame has
hit point two billion dollars you saw
the movie you know what I'm referencing
before we get into that I do want to say
that this is gonna be no spoilers in
here I wanted to say thank you to
everyone who has checked out our
non-spoiler review have an opening
sketcher thank you for all the kind
comments we've been getting especially
on all over social media - and it would
also checked out her spoiler talk but I
wanted to make a special mention to a
man named Supes he has his own YouTube
channel soups channel I recently did an
hour-long spoiler discussion with him
and the channel the cosmic Wonder he has
about 370 thousand followers huge comic
book nerd both of these gentleman's are
even though we did our own spoiler talk
on this channel the spoiler talk there
was very different and I covered a lot
of ground we did not cover on this
channel the beginning of our spoiler
talk I even said that I could talk about
this movie for hours and then hop it
over to there diving into different
things and even revisiting some things
from a different angle it was really
cool and I think you guys would really
enjoy that talks go check it out the
link is in the description boxes also as
a pin comment do it today people all
right so the box office support for
Avengers endgame I'm gonna tell you I
put out a tweet today and I share it on
the community page when I was looking at
the box office report I was like oh man
Drew's endgame hit one point two billion
dollars global opening weekend oh that's
cool new record awesome yeah and that
wasn't a surprise what took me for a
huge surprise you know some people are
gonna play cool and some people are
gonna be like you come but no one
predicted this 350 million dollars
opening weekend I did not know even
though we had enough theaters to match
that man well I figured they would get
the opening night record that they broke
but yeah the entire weekend and to get
like the largest grossing Saturday the
largest grossing Sunday I have all those
individual days I mean you gotta imagine
that every theater is playing this
across as many screens as they can
because it's also such a thick movie
that it becomes them to put it in as
many screens as possible if any movie is
gonna get the benefit of the most amount
of screens it's probably this
for sure the vengers infinity war I
believed open up to 257 million dollars
this is almost a hundred million dollars
more I feel like the best analysts they
said that most it might do is three
hundred million dollars but I don't know
it's just like 350 damn no wonder when I
went to we saw this opening at an arc
light show times for no other movie yeah
I'm surprised there's other movies in
the top ten of the box office right now
because there were literally no show
times for anything else at a theater
that had like 20 screens available you
know this is an awesome time to be
living in and I'm so happy for this film
because like I've said many times
already this is my favorite Marvel movie
so far my favorite MCU movie so far I'm
just so happy for everyone involved I
mean it broke the Thursday preview of
which is what Star Wars The Force
awakens held any record infinity war
held over the weekend among its demolish
that fastest movie to cross a billion
dollars in just a few days I remember
like when Captain Marvel came out I was
thinking that I think the benefit that
they're doing with releasing Captain
Marvel so close to end game is that
they're hoping that'll actually increase
the box office numbers for Captain
Marvel oh yeah one and and hyping up her
importance to the in game overall and
stuff like that and their relation as
movies yeah it was more waiting sometime
to feature her in the trailers and the
Captain Marvel I mean it's not doing any
game numbers it's cross the Billy & N
games already crossed what Captain
Marvel Captain Marvel is number two at
the box office so we got two MCU films
number one and number two like am I
surprised that it's killing the box
office and shattering records know what
took me for a loop was 350 million
dollars in like damn how do i do not
even fathom that you had a defeater
through that that's the budget for one
of these first three hour movie - yeah
and a lot of those theaters have about
20 minutes of trailers so that's why I
was really shocked by that and it makes
me wonder you know without going into
spoilers you know spider-man far from
home is the next movie and I know that
after Avengers Assemble the first one
the Joss Whedon made Iron Man 3 was the
first movie and that movie crossed a
billion dollars so that's also Iron Man
right
the wave of vendors assemble I know a
man and the loss was the first movie
after infinity war that did not do as
well as Marvel probably had hope at the
same time though they've already
established well before and game came
out the Spider Man far from home is
taking place after endgame and it's
supposed to be the that's supposed to
actually be the final part of this phase
if I'm correct about that you can
correct me but I believe that's what
Marvel's 10:5 you said yeah I feel like
with everything of you know why they say
don't spoil the end game cuz there's so
much to spoil and then with spider-man
coming back I'm now thinking like this
could this be the first spider-man movie
to cross a billion dollars after
everything that endgame has set up
themselves I wonder I mean I think
spider-man will certainly do well cuz
people are really hyped to see Mysterio
and stuff like that and I'm sure people
really psyched to have spider-man back
and all that I definitely think the
enthusiasm will carry I expected to do
better than like an ant-man the wasp per
se because I think there's a just a
stronger association with the spider-man
films perhaps but yeah I'm curious
definitely because of the way people
theorize the way that home are far from
home maybe ties into either infinity war
or endgame where is this trip taking
place is this part of one of these
timelines like I think that will
definitely accelerate some of its
earnings but I don't think it'll do
these numbers yeah won't do these
numbers but it might be cool to get the
first spider-man movie to finally
because I think spider-man homecoming
made about 880 million worldwide but
that would be pretty cool for the first
I think with all this hype I mean it's
just that all that talk about like you
know comic-book fatigue is nowhere to be
seen right now you make a good movie
with some interesting emotional stakes
and stuff like that I think poor movies
like Shazam and Hellboy that have come
out I mean help I was already not doing
great but yeah personally did okay but
not as great as everybody at Hope know
it's not the John Campea show we were
talking about how long we think it'll be
number one at the box office at least
domestically and I was thinking that if
it has a chance of beating out detective
Pikachu us into the next big movie
release it has a chance of possibly
beating out I didn't feel like it was
likely before these numbers came in I
was that fell I got a text a Pikachu
might still open up to number one at the
box office but now I'm like rethinking
my whole thought
wait a minute people are definitely
watching this again there's a little bit
more high where people are already got
tickets again for a third screening and
I feel like there's even more hype for
people who haven't seen it yet who are
like okay I really got to see this movie
and I feel like that's just gonna keep
on going for such a long time now I'm
thinking it probably will beat detective
Pikachu maybe even if it's if I could by
a small margin because I know there
tends to be a big box office drop second
weekend even if this dropped like 65
percent that's still a lot of money yeah
I mean I guess just me I would expect
endgame to hold on very strongly or yeah
at least edge out detective because you
could detect a Pikachu is a more
family-friendly movie so you'll get more
people at a time going to see it this is
just such a huge event that people who
aren't even invested in all of the films
are probably gonna be checking out then
you'll have people for whom this is
their Dark Knight where they're gonna
see a seven or eight times
I feel like endgame is going to hold on
a nice long while even a face of some of
these pretty big other tentpole movies
coming out and it'll be interesting to
see it's been since at least infinity
war that we've had a movie of such huge
proportions out there you know well I
think by that time reaches the Vlada and
it definitely won't be number one no
Disney will knock themselves yeah sure I
mean this is also the movie in terms of
like CinemaScore the third movie in the
MCU to get an a-plus cinema score which
is the highest you can get next to the
first Avengers movie and black panther I
just think the legs on this are gonna be
freakin insane and even when it's not
number one it's gonna I I feel like this
could finally be the movie that beats
out avatar actually I think it handily
has at least an advantage in that happy
berries I mean I wouldn't be surprised
if it doesn't just because James Cameron
train is this is the thing that seems
like really hard to beat when James
Cameron directs the next Avengers right
yeah it'll happen it brings up a whole
new technology
this has more competition coming its way
as opposed to when avatar did come out
this coming month alone you got
detective Pikachu Aladdin
Godzilla king of the monsters as our
hunt with Johnny yeah I mean John
Blake's knocking out really up there
with those no but it does have a good
- it will take some some with it yeah I
don't know I'm just I'm excited about
this news I felt like maybe 282 290
million but damn this is this really
took me for a loop yeah go on and I had
no idea what to expect I just knew it
was going to be big and it was probably
going to be a surprise yeah yeah this is
just a special movie alright guys well
how long do you think it'll be number
one at the box office put it in the
comments below before this video is done
I would like to give a special page from
the day shout out to a fairly new patron
his name is Pete Don we had an opening
in our slot for a top reporter he took
it right away he took that slot because
we're in the middle of a movie might see
some boxes here behind John we have to
be out of here by Wednesday morning he
was very understanding and said that he
wants to wait two whole offer and has a
video request for me so thanks for
offering that dude this guy is from Ohio
I asked him what his passion is Anika's
John has a lot of family in Ohio so I
was like you might be John one day
that's what his passion was in Nene he
had of his biggest hope he said I'm 22
big in a superhero stuff videogames
bowling I want to be a as well and he's
really into clubbing that was the last
one I did not see cover so I really hear
someone say superhero stuff video games
bowling I'm like oh man this guy has
like all my things right there and
clubbing yeah getting out there some big
lapels doing some dance movie and down
and dirty on about comics well you know
you're bumping grad feet I'm happy to
know you man I'm happy to have you part
of our page from page I appreciate you
being patient with us and I'm hoping
that you stick around for a long time
because you seem like a really friendly
guy and hopefully we can go take ecstasy
together one day and even though you say
you're completely sober I'm gonna ruin
that for you dude we are gonna get you
to relapse as soon as possible you guys
can subscribe to the react nation click
that notification bell make sure to
check out that collab with Supes
and the cosmic Wonder it's a great video
trust me on that you'll have a good time